to culinary genius five home cooks are
about to go head-to-head across two
intense rounds of challenges in a fight
to the finish and super chef Gordon
Ramsay will be on hand to give us his
top tips for the day our contestants
have each brought their favorite item
from their kitchen at home to help them
today so we're gonna see about that
overseeing the competition is renowned
chef with a string of restaurants to his
name Edward Lee so what do you have in
store for the contestants today all
right so today we have a simple butchery
challenge now the three cooks who do the
best in this challenge will move on to
the next round
so let's reveal today's ingredient
contestants please lift your cloches
it's chicken
no before Edward reveals the details of
today's challenge here is super chef
Gordon Ramsay with his top tips on how
to get the best out of your bird hi guys
today I gonna be cooking with this
incredible juicy chicken now where is
the breast the thigh or the drum trust
me every part of this delicious chicken
can be incredible what's my favorite way
I would say a pan seared breast
beautifully caramelized but sat on a bed
of wild mushrooms so Edward what's the
first challenge art LED cooks are faced
with today thanks Gordon all right today
cooks I want you to take this chicken
and butcher it into ten parts two wings
two breasts
two thighs two drums and two oysters are
you ready okay pull the wing all the way
back lift it up find where that joint is
you're gonna take your boning knife and
you're gonna just carefully go around
don't go all the way through just go
around once you come here you're gonna
pull that thing you see that bone gets
reveal okay now watch this you can just
pop that bone it comes right out one way
same thing on the other side all right
let's go down to the legs just cut down
here make a nice little slit right down
here and you're gonna reveal the meat at
this point you don't need your knife
just use your fingers to kind of pry
that open and then you're gonna just pop
that right out you hear that and then
you can use your boning knife and just
trim right along there okay now you want
to separate the drum from the thigh so
take your heel of your palm and just go
right through okay now for the thigh
meat we want to debone it I'm gonna go
back to my boning knife and just kind of
scrape down see how easy that is and
just keep coming down down down
do cut that right off okay now you have
a beautiful side
right there now we get to the breasts
you're gonna make a small incision right
along there and then just start making
small cuts and really all I'm doing is
just releasing the meat from the bone
coming right around there
perfect now but Easter it's a little
pocket of flesh that goes right above
the thigh mate and you're gonna just
gently carve right about that okay
that's it they're tiny little things but
they're delicious
now what I'm gonna look for is a
beautiful presentation no feathers a
very nice butchery all right back to
your station
All Right contestants you have ten
minutes let the battle begin what is
your favorite way to cook with chicken
all right getting some spices into it
you know chicken is kind of bland so I
love you know Asian spices coconut
garlic ginger a little bit of curry let
that braise but you really want to win
my heart and also just fry it up I'm
from the south fried chicken that's true
that gives it enough flavor that oh yeah
all right let's go on and see how
they're doing on it hello Cheryl how do
you feel it's gonna go here well I'm
feeling pretty okay know how the
chickens gonna fare I think I'm gonna be
all right
have you ever butcher the chicken have
not first time yes and your
demonstration something I learned on the
way thank you
David are you doing good you're from
Maryland yeah I am alright so you got a
secret Maryland chicken recipe
no usually crab but I'm hoping to do
with chip you can stuff like that we'll
keep it going give a nice handle on that
thank you all right thanks David you're
a little tentative with that knife or
you squeamish at all yeah show that
chicken who's boss who's the boss of
this chicken so I hear you're a big
hunter well I was yeah so have you
butchered much since you hunt yes
anytime I'm successful harvesting an
animal will butcher it all right so this
is old hat food yeah well I'm not so
good at bird hunting okay I spend little
time working on chickens as well thank
you enjoy
all right contestants we are at the
halfway mark we are the halfway point
this is your first time butchering a
chicken that is correct so how do you
buy your chicken normally just buy him a
pre-cut yes pre-cut and I usually buy
skinless try just keep in shape but
today cooking for you will definitely be
using that beautiful skin give us okay
right so we had a chance to talk to
everybody who do you feel struggling the
most you know definitely anumita
is having a little bit of problems
getting those fine cuts off that meat
ten-nine down time is just attempted to
joint a chicken like a chef but only
three can make it through to the final
round where they get to create a dish
fit for a restaurant menu time to find
out what Edward thinks of their efforts
so let's start with Cheryl so you only
got seven out of ten I don't see any
oysters the pieces that you were able to
get look pretty good good on you for
that
but you only got something that time
hello there David I can just look at
your carcass let's see it's clean the
meat is off the bone just from looking
at this I can tell you did a pretty good
job let's see how your deboning is done
here beautiful
you got all 10 pieces it's beautiful
make sure and unita what happens here
you were supposed to show the chicken
ruthbarz I think so chicken got the best
out of you my goodness what happened
here this is like something
all right correct you got all 10 pieces
that's a good start it's a little sloppy
looks a little bit like you went hunting
in the wild and just butcher the chicken
but overall you got all 10 pieces there
on the board and they do look pretty
good all right susannah judgement time I
may have done four quantity are you
trying to show me up it's a little bit
rushed but you know you exceeded
expectations but remember it's quality
over quantity okay all right it's time
for Edward to tell us who will be
staying in the competition the first
contestant going through to the final is
David is Craig final contestant to go
through to the final is Susana of course
tell her that means that we have to say
goodbye to Cheryl and and yanita thank
you so much for joining us here today
now all that stands between our three
remaining contestants and $1,000 is the
final cook-off now they must use the
chicken they've already prepared to make
a sumptuous mouth-watering dish so enter
what are you looking for from those
three finalists I want to see a
perfectly cooked chicken dish with your
personality in that place now
contestants before you wade into battle
you'll need to stock up of course on
some ingredients from our pantry you
have just two minutes to get whatever
you want and your time starts now
I lots of deliciousness there that
pantry what's there for today keep
throwing in some really global
influences right so we've got couscous
we've got rice noodles we have sun-dried
tomatoes chorizo from the produce side
they've got pomegranates they have pop
joy they have bean sprouts I mean we've
got an incredible pantry they should
have no problems being inspired by this
pantry
I took her an approach of get everything
to make sure I didn't forget anything so
I had a lot of ingredients certainly got
all the ones that I needed for my recipe
trying to have a game plan there with
what you're grabbing two things I'm
still thinking of making I haven't
decided yet but I think I've got to go
with something I know I can get done in
25 minutes here we go guys ten nine
eight seven six five three
okay you have 25 minutes to create your
winning chicken dish let the final
battle begin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
David we're sneaking up right behind you
what's up with this deep fryer I'm gonna
fry the wings and what did you bring
from home
Chinese preserved vegetables doing
moderately confident at this time I'm
really just concerned about the time 25
minutes is really short and I'm worried
I'm not gonna be able to get it all done
in time oh hey there Craig hi so what
did you grab from the pantry today garam
masala turmeric paprika okay lots of
great specialty here some chili powder
throw that all together saute it build
some flavor with the onions garlic I'll
throw the chicken in and just stir fry
it so click you don't believe in
vegetables I'm gonna son says I'm a meat
at Aryan okay let's promise you alright
say okay you're gonna do a chicken curry
chicken curry with one piece of flimsy
bok choy that's Michael I'm used to
going out and cooking for the guys in
the hunting camp it's all protein
there's no vegetables I've left it to
veg on that pantry hi there's Susanna
chorizo in here yeah sauteed chicken
breast with chorizo and bean stuffing
you've grabbed about 400 ingredients
from the pantry white wine I want to see
a unified dish don't just so you know
pull put three of stuff into a pan okay
stay focused all right so David there
looked like he was buttering you up with
a fried chicken that could be my
favorite meal of the day and also David
he brought these preserved vegetables
from home do you think that's gonna play
well into this dish
have a subtly kind of slip it in there
it'll be beautiful
well Craig looks like a really confident
cook do you think he's been able to
carry off this chicken Salah curry I
love a chicken curry but if you don't
have any vegetables you don't anything
you've no delicacy no balance no
complexity he'd be just a chicken right
Susana really impressed you with how she
chopped up the chicken portioned it out
do you think she's gonna impress you
with the way she carries off this meal I
hope she knows how to balance it because
again you put too many things it's just
gonna be a plate of confusion and I
don't want anything I'm a little nervous
my chicken is not cooking all the way
through it's very thick hopefully it'll
get finished what would you have took
today I love the idea of a curry you
know I would do a chicken thigh if I
crisp up the skin on one side flip it
over coconut milk do some curry do some
tumors a little fresh ginger garlic let
that braise for a little bit do some bok
choy finish it off with fresh cilantro
leave all right cooks we are at the
halfway mark halfway mark you're doing
well keep it going
three remaining home cooks are in the
midst of a culinary battle to impress
Edward Lee with their chicken dishes and
win today's show so let's see how they
are doing
hey there Craig here you are a
stay-at-home dad you do most of the
cooking for your two kids and teenagers
are they're pretty finicky right and
actually your wife is here today thank
you
David it is smelling great over here you
look very busy you have some some
supporters in the audience your two
daughters are here right yes my wife is
there as well
it's he a great cook an amazing chef yes
it's a cooked you said yeah absolutely
great dads cooking today will continue
on because we're just down to the final
minutes here thank you
hey Susanna if you had an opportunity to
win this what would you do with the
money can I go to Gordon's restaurant
they're gonna spend thousand bucks at
Gordon's rather that's a lot of good
meal that's maybe some travel one of
those two you look very busy right no we
had a lot of ingredients but it looks
like you're putting them to good use I
hope so we'll see I'm gonna let you
think to it then all right thank you
Greg how you doing rushed rushed yeah
you got a few minutes left listen this
smells absolutely amazing how you
feeling great
good good no pressure but the world is
watching I'm judging put everything onto
the plate okay are you hungry
yes I am does the way I try to do when I
serve my friends I try to make sure I'm
really late to preparing and presenting
all right so they're really starving by
the time they get perfect thank you
think about that presentation all right
yes good luck
two minutes left guys David how you
doing I'm okay to put on a plate right I
do okay
what's this here mushrooms over there
yeah I just thought there was too much
for the plate listen make sure none of
it stays in the pan that's okay all
right
good luck thank you I am a bit worried
I've bitten off more than I can chew but
I figure let's go big or go home
Susannah what's going on there's a mad
scientist experiment here Wow
this kitchen just exploded on me and I
think you used them all
listen presentation presentation okay
focus don't play it up too early because
the food's gonna get cold all right get
everything in your head
focus good luck thank you I started
plating early because I knew the other
chefs sometimes run out of time but I
wanted to make sure to get everything on
the plate and set it down visually so it
looked perfect
give us David's gotta hurry up he's got
too many things he's trying to do on the
plate it's not on there yet
Susanna's already got her food plated
which worries me a little bit as the
chicken might try ash has got it's my
stuff and Craig I got I hope that curry
is good because that's all he's got oh
yeah exactly
guys it's got to look good please not
just taste good looks matter ten nine
eight seven six
[Applause]
to the final part of culinary genius
where it is time for Edward to judge our
cooks creation so let's go in I've
plated my dish might get cold but they
don't have enough spice and sass in it
to be delicious I think it's done I'm a
bit worried the chicken might be
overdone if anything hope I've done
enough I'm okay with a limited amount of
vegetables on the plate is it a
well-balanced meal maybe not but I'm
sure it'll work out fine listen if
you're not going to do a lot of stuff
you got to present it so that the plate
looks like it's filled out this looks
like you've sort of left something in
the pan but let's go and try this
chicken
I can tell you've made this before
because absolutely brilliant it's so
delicious I could eat an entire bowl of
just this chicken curry it's fantastic
your bok choy I don't know what you did
with it but it's beautiful it's got a
little bit of vinegar to it it's got a
little spice to it it's really crunchy I
wish I had more of that bok choy because
it's so brilliant mm-hmm the noodles
however really dry there's kind of no
flavor in it I wish you to sort of put
the noodles in the middle and then put
the curry on top of it and put all that
sauce over then it would flavor the
noodles but man you killed it with that
curry I'm not sure how to eat this
because I usually eat chicken with my
fingers but you've got stuff that
requires a fork so let's go in okay I'm
gonna try this mmm listen you got a lot
going on here I'm gonna start with the
good stuff the mushrooms are absolutely
delicious the pickles are perfect your
chicken even though I don't like the
fact that you put a wing on this place
it should be a beautiful composed plate
it was really nicely salted and it just
like made my heart explode I know you're
really nervous before but you finally
have it plated how do you feel about it
I'm excited I hope that Jeff likes it I
can already tell it's a little bit dry
that you cut it too early and you plated
it too early and what happens when you
do that you draw it out it's a little
bit monotone we have a beautiful pantry
I would love to see some kind of green
or something that make it pop
I like the way you cook the chicken is
really nice you crisp the skin which is
really beautiful that's a technique that
I was looking for I was hoping to see
and you did it I think you fell for the
trap of just too many ingredients and
throw it onto a plate but it's delicious
I like the chicken I like it very much
needs a little bit of color but overall
beautiful job it has been an intense
battle but Edward has chosen his Victor
[Music]
finalists please lift your cloches
[Music]
this was a seriously close battle I
think what brought it over the edge was
your dedication you brought so many
different elements in them and that
chicken was salted perfectly so
congratulations David you're the winner
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]